hello Louis hello Miss Moore
Eddie is everything all right can I talk
to you about something
sure
we've both been on our own for years I'm
lonely and I'm guessing you might be too
how long have we known each other longer
we've been neighbors we don't really
know each other how about we get to know
each other I don't want anybody to think
anything bad you know how it is people
talk it's not about sex it's about
getting through the night I think I
could sleep again if there was somebody
next to me here Oh someone nice
[Music]
and now let's turn the merry way hmm you
wake up one morning and you have
everything and the next morning it's all
gone
[Music]
where do we go to town that lunch sounds
fine to me maybe I'll wear something
bright and flashy why me I always
thought you were a good man of us a good
one maybe that's not a great one
now
[Music]
some things we can't fix what should we
do about it
we could try talking what do you think
about that oh I think that's a good idea
never know what it might lead to
sugar rain
[Music]
you